ich habe euch eine zahl mit gebracht
hier heute in die runde und die hat mehr
vergangene woche richtig zu denken
gegeben wir geben über 7 milliarden euro
und die verlieren die deutschen aktuell
jeden monat wenn man es mal runter
rechnet oft einen einzelnen
durchschnittlichen haushalt dann sind
das 150 euro die sind einfach weg monat
für monat für monat das problem ist auf
dem papier dieses geld natürlich weiter
da aber wir sehen sehr aktuell an den
preisen alles wird teurer die
lebensmittelpreise die benzinpreise wir
können mit dem geld einfach weniger
kaufen die deutschen sind eigentlich
meister im sparen doch sie machen einen
fatalen fehler und zwar in der gesamten
mehrheit sie lassen ihr geld auf dem
konto und da gibt's wir wissen schon
lange keine zinsen mehr im gegenteil mit
anderen worten die deutschen sparen sich
arm und das obwohl die lösung so einfach
wäre wir müssen einfach mehr in aktien
investieren dass die meisten das immer
noch versäumen liegt in meinen augen
aber auch an der politik denn es gibt
immer noch viel zu viele politiker die
es entweder nicht verstehen wollen oder
die einfach keinen plan davon haben den
eindruck hatten wir als wir vor der
bundestagswahl mit einigen jungen
nachwuchs politikerinnen und politikern
gesprochen haben welche fatalen folgen
das für unser land hat würde ich gerne
mit euch diskutieren ja also er spricht
mir aus der seele diese auffassung teile
ich übrigens seit vielen jahren es gibt
da ein mentalitätsproblem aus meiner
sicht in unserem land beim thema aktien
es fängt sehr früh an also es fängt aus
meiner sicht schon in der schule an wie
man sich mit dem thema wirtschaft oder
wirtschaftswissenschaften auseinander
also beschäftigt das hatte und dort
fehlen oft grundlagen um bestimmte dinge
oder wirtschaftsprozesse prozesse zu
verstehen und eins muss man auch sagen
wer sich in deutschland für aktien
interessiert selbst wenn er ein bisschen
know how hat dann geht man zu einer bank
will eine beratung ich glaube auf der
seite auch die beratung in deutschland
da ist noch deutlich viel luft nach oben
ja klar man kann jetzt sagen was was
macht die politik kann da die politik
nicht anreize schaffen ich glaube die
politik in deutschland ist zumindest ein
spiegelbild der gesellschaft und
wenn die gesellschaft kein kein
vertrauen hat weil das thema vertrauen
spielt ja auch bei dem thema gerade beim
aktien eine große rolle aber wenn die
mentalität so ist dass man kein
vertrauen zu aktienmärkten hat dann ist
es ihnen liegt in der natur der sache
dass teile der politik das ja auch so
sehen es gibt es gibt länder wo die
aktienkultur allein dieses wort
aktienkultur das gibt es in deutschland
nicht aber es gibt länder wo aktien zum
beispiel eine wesentliche komponente der
altersvorsorge sind das ist in
deutschland für viele in der politik die
debatten werden wir übrigens auch
demnächst haben bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen aber das ist für
viele in der politik auch merkwürdig
nach dem motto wie soll das
funktionieren also ich will es so schön
und seien deswegen ist das ist
zum beispiel dass das aktien auch ein
teil also kapitalgedeckte altersvorsorge
einen teil genau die aktien rente auch
eine natürliche komponente sein soll
dies sinnvoll das bestehende system
ergänzen kann das ist eine debatte die
könnte man
bereit dafür während der ampel aus
meiner sicht ist das eine sehr sinnvolle
ergänzung und es gibt ja beispiel es
gibt ja staaten die das probieren
schweden schweden ein soziales land
durch und durch sozial aufgestellt das
land hat dieses system das sind teil des
gehaltes ist sehr gering ich glaube eher
zu 2,5 prozent oder so in so einer
komponente
einbezahlt wird und das funktioniert und
ist eine sinnvolle ergänzung also ich
muss da wirklich mal eine lanze auch für
die deutschen brechen das sind immer
diejenigen die relativ gut verdienen und
die auf die zeiten haben sich die börsen
teilen der zeitungen durchzulesen die
mit diesem vorschlag kommen ich erinnere
mich noch gut wie man versucht hat bei
gelegenheit der telekom nach einem
volksaktie daraus zu machen und die
deutschen mal so richtig schön an zu
animieren doch telekom aktien zu kaufen
wir alle telefonieren du hast an die
aktien und es geht nach oben es brach
dann ein und manfred krug als
werbeträger war der buhmann der nation
es gibt im übrigen auch eine aktion
sommer ja im sommer musste dann gehen am
ende es gibt im übrigen eine eine aktien
rente dass die heißt riester und da hat
der staat tatsächlich versucht die
mentalität der deutschen so weit zu
berücksichtigen dass es mit sehr vielen
sicherung mechanismen behaftet hat und
zulagen gegeben hat die riester rente
ist so kompliziert wenn das häkchen an
der falschen stelle setzt und inzwischen
unmittelbar und mittelbar
zulageberechtigt wird das zurückgebucht
aus dem letzten jahren so versinkt in
bürokratie furchtbar leid aber an zwei
punkten ganz gern wieder sprechen du
sagst man muss geld haben und du sagst
es ist kompliziert man muss sich richtig
damit auseinandersetzen das ist gar
nicht der punkt den ich den leuten
empfehlen würde sondern es gibt ein
vehikel sag ich mal eine methode wie man
relativ leicht
einen das thema aktien rein kommen kann
ist nämlich etf ctf ist nichts anderes
als ein korb da sind verschiedenste
aktien drin nehmen wir als beispiel
einen auf den dax da sind ihm alle 40
dax-unternehmen drin du kaufst davon
anteile jeden monat mit einem kleinen
betrag 25 euro 50 euro reichen schon und
du kannst auf die art wenn du jetzt als
25-jähriger anfängst bis zur rente so
einen riesen vermögen ansparen was dir
sehr sehr helfen wird angesichts der
tatsache dass unsere gesetzliche rente
ja nur auf sehr wackligen füßen stehe
das stimmt aber nur wenn beim
renteneintritt gerade irgendeine
weltwirtschaftskrise die krise die
aktienmärkte nach unten zieht dann ist
man gut bedient wenn man beispielsweise
das ganze parallel durch anleihenkäufe
viel abgefedert hat das muss man aber
erst mal drauf haben eröffnen wir ein
online depot bei einer bank dann ist der
gesetzgeber so eifrig gewesen dass man
seine aktien wissen nachweisen muss also
entweder man lügt der bank die hucke
voll und setzt häkchen dass man zehn
jahre und mehr in internationalen
anleihen in nationalen anleihen in
kredit fand obligationen erfahrung hat
oder man bekommt das depot nicht das ist
schon relativ schwierig dagegen schon
viele auf und diejenigen die mit einer
schwarzen null am monatsende aus dem auf
dem girokonto außen monat gehen die
möchten gerne die sicherheit haben dass
sie zu dem zeitpunkt wenn ihr auto
kaputt geht und sie brauchen jetzt 3000
euro das dann auch 3000 euro da sind und
nicht gerade weil eine base irgendwo auf
der welt die märkte runterzieht es
leider nur 2600 sind und sie müssen dann
den teuren dispokredit noch dazu nehmen
deswegen sage ich ganz bewusst kleiner
betrag 50 euro im monat reicht und wenn
du zwölf jahre das machst zueinander
maßen ist eine weile hin aber ich
spreche vor allem die berufstätigen
jetzt hier an die vielleicht im beruf so
die ersten drei vier fünf sechs jahre
hinter sich du wirst wenn du es ab holte
sich der heilige nikolaus haben es
zumindest wenn du auf die historischen
daten chance hätte ja noch einen
angenehmen nebeneffekt vielleicht ist
mir die deutschen dann führte zu
kapitalisten werden das ja auch nicht
schlecht wenn man wenn man zum beispiel
ist für vw aktie hat dann wird man
vielleicht nicht mit man vielleicht
genauer hinschauen wenn du bist ja immer
klima klima kleben hat soll ich immer
noch über nachverbrennung momentan aber
wir haben das wie oft er schon mal
wieder aktien man kann auch eine grüne
nein aber ich meistens schon es ist
schon richtig dass wir dass wir das doch
deutschland ist im industrieland ist
wäre schon nicht schlecht wenn die leute
auch interesse an der anderen industrien
haben und kein gehör sollte auch jeder
location punkt alexander peer group
angehört hat auch ein stück vom
unternehmen und was ja auch so spannend
ist es macht ja auch interesse also was
ja wirklich weg die auch interesse an
der bildschirm eines weiß ich sagen
gemacht und wenn man 50 euro dann an vw
hat und dann gucken wir immer auf den
aktienkursen dann fängt man mehr über vw
zu lesen oder bei daimler oder der
richtigen autos und umgebung effekt
darüber nachzudenken dass
rasch autogramme unternehmen ich muss
auch sagen ich bin der aktienkultur auch
sehr aufgeschlossen gegenüber und mich
regt es wirklich auf wenn dann politiker
immer noch über sparbuch reden weil das
ist wirklich geld verbrennen deswegen
verstehe ich deine these da sind wir
einer meinung die deutschen werden am
sparen und ich versuche auch immer dafür
zu werben dass man sich damit
auseinandersetzt wird gesagt 25 euro das
ist ja auch so es wird immer vorgelebt
nur die reichen können investiert wenn
das hat ein beispiel auch gezahlt und
jeder kann investieren um da vielleicht
noch was konstruktives der politik mit
auf den weg zu geben wir sind ja auch
eine sendung der lebenshilfe
die politik ist permanent dabei große
aufgaben zu wälzen jetzt den klimawandel
zu managen da werden pakete geschnürt
von der europäischen union und auch von
der bundesregierung im mehrfachen
milliarden bis hin zum millionenbereich
was hindert denn die politik daran fonds
festverzinslich aufzulegen die der
kleinen sparer kaufen kann wo er weiß
nach zehn jahren bekommt erfolgende
rendite raus der staat muss ohnehin
anleihen aufnehmen da geht er jetzt zu
banken und leiht sich doch das geld mit
volatilen zinsen die ja nicht genau
einschätzen kann warum kann man sowas
nicht auch für die eigene bevölkerung
machen japan beispielsweise ist fast
ausschließlich bei der eigenen
bevölkerung verschuldet bei der
staatsverschuldung mit dem nebeneffekt
dass die renten dort sehr viel sicherer
sind weil viele japaner eben die eigenen
anleihen gekauft haben und es hindert
den start ein wenig daran irgendwelche
zins schnitte oder ähnliches zu machen
weil man weiß dass man dann sofort die
eigene leute aufnehmen also im moment
fehlt mir für den vorschlag ein bisschen
die fantasie denn der staat kann derzeit
negative zinsen geld aufnehmen
deutschland ist so ein guter sohn
guter schuldner das große investoren
sogar noch auf ein teil des geldes
verzichten und natürlich auch per und
dann ralf funktioniert ja die idee nicht
aber vielleicht wenn wir wieder
steigende zinsen haben die politik kann
natürlich klar kann die politik anreize
schaffen das muss auch die politik an
der stelle die politik könnte auch
hingehen und sagen wir machen
aktieninvestitionen steuerlich
interessanter dass das das geht aber am
ende des tages kamen wir immer zu dem
grundproblem zurück es ist die
mentalität der deutschen und das ist ein
stück problematisch im zusammenhang mit
den aktien ich habe ende der 90er jahre
bwl studiert alle die ihn derzeit
studiert haben oder viele hatten damals
die vorstellung da wird sofort danach
ein unternehmen gegründet kurz danach an
die börse dass er damals gab es noch
diese mentalität dann kamen einige
erfahrungen die dot-com-blase
telekom-aktien das hat alles in der zeit
eine rolle gespielt heute wenn ich mich
mit bwl absolventen unterhalte höre ich
oft also wollte ich nach dem studium hin
der öffentliche dienst also das ist es
ist es ist jetzt wieder ein thema wieder
was anderes aber dass auf jeden fall
parallele mit dem thema aktien vorhanden
[Musik]